[Music]
in sad times news submitted by JK news
guys are hot okay I remember you have
one
yeah we need props we never get prompt
yeah ever a newly erected pedestrian
bridge collapsed killing six people oh
[ __ ] you lost like I got stuck on
corrected no disgusting I know
so then Everett a newly erected I'm like
war yeah no I heard I heard that and
then I didn't hear the rest of the one
theme I was reading it what are so
sexually deprived you know I know I'm
gonna give it tonight don't worry about
that we don't want it if you want it
exactly yeah this looks kinda like
reverse rape
[Laughter]
there's no rapist so what do you guys
want no we don't want on purpose yes
exactly so when our dick is limp and
we're like I'm tired we don't want to do
any work so we just want you to like
know that now it's doing now it's time
if you don't know then what the [ __ ]
what the hell - watch yourself walk in
it up point it's like you never want to
have sex figure it out I know I don't
I'm tired these days I wake up at 6:00
in the morning
no I know you push-ups
I know it's tough to do gene anymore
salad like this testosteron gets built
up and then he like wants to [ __ ] a lot
you know yeah maybe I got to do more
push-ups or maybe we're doing too much
push-ups and we go out too high also you
ki can hold you down sorry we can't hold
you just get you a headlock try and go
somewhere like I can't Indian Bollywood
movie I can't
[Laughter]
so did you guys hear about the bridge in
Miami broke so the bridge serious people
died did it really makes people die that
his soul [ __ ] up what happened so this
bridge in Miami oh yes
but you know like how many people have
to die for you too one is already two
men even one person dying is horrible
right okay for sure should start with
that
that's horrible people thought just
based off of the shock factor news I've
been gating I'm solely sensitive so
desensitized aside
we're twelve people died oh my oh that's
here also for you use for you it's like
oh thank God it wasn't twenty I was
thinking it was gonna be a because
that's how I feel like the news the news
stations are there like you give T
people died and then they're like well
wait till it's fifty before we send our
vans over there you just can't grade
like I give that one a C+ like why are
we talking it's not an A+ like there
wasn't 20 to 50 you know there's a
there's a psychology test like that have
you guys heard of the one where there's
a train coming yep you heard about this
one no okay so like all you save your
dear people or the whole train that one
do you save one person yeah or no the
trains fine but they there's like two
different tracks that could be on one
has someone that needs very close to you
that's on the track and then the other
one has five people that are strangers
all the five are dying for sure yes
just hope that you're not on a train
that I have to decide there's like a
fork in the road because you're probably
not the person who kills the one versus
the five strangers that's the crazy
person the person that saves the loved
one is the crazy person now the killer
kills the loved one is because they all
they see is numbers they go well I
rather save five lives than one life
well Bart yep I was gonna choose here's
another one okay so which one is the
right one to choose okay you're on the
bridge right and then let's say you you
have a chance to saving like this does
runaway trains going down and it's gonna
and it's gonna crash into five five kids
right but all you got to do is press
this button and then this person that's
on the bridge will fall down and he
would stop the train because the train
will run over this one person what do
you do it oh we save the kids so no love
don't see the kids no loved ones no
loved ones know how many kids
oh I'm saving the kid five kids there's
there's five kids yeah yeah yeah the
person already lived a good life yes all
you got to do is so you your controller
you just hit the button well there's a
follow-up question to that yeah so so
everyone would save the kids right yeah
okay now imagine you're on the bridge
with this person the train's coming and
the way that you can probably stop this
train is if you push this person over
the bridge oh [ __ ] I bet you saved the
kids yeah but you're now a murderer no
you guys not pressing the button you
think I just have to look at a verse
just kind of balance itself out at that
point I'm just like what you gotta do
versatility hit the button like I'd be
like Oh
to you director you so so the second one
is you have to push this person we we
create our own on I probably go push
them up oh yeah you're all normal
because I paid the kid the crazy person
will they won't be able to tell the
difference they're like what's the
difference between pushing a button and
pushing that person they're like it's
the same thing
but then for most people it's like it's
like oh it's too personal like if you
think about it right we just say hey you
know what one of us has to die let's
brawl but hopefully the person smaller
it's too late yeah cuz like they'll just
push you someone that's died let's do it
yeah but then based on how you push me
you flew back here let's get to the bad
[ __ ] let's do it we've been [ __ ]
putting it off we're doing this on
purpose you guys we don't have very much
I'll treat you guys from this hell no I
want to shelter myself I'm just
preparing myself for this [ __ ] unicorns
and rainbows guys this is a brand new
pedestrian bridge that had just been
corrected oh the [ __ ] built it some
Chinese people so it's not even made for
cars walking only yeah but uh and so
they recently opened it so head open on
Saturday but then by that Thursday is
when I collapse it was erected but it
had whiskey dick cuz it was built on
outside oh my god it was real didn't it
was erected in just six hours oh no like
oh it's like a carnival it's like a
carnival bridge well I mean this is like
a brand-new type of bridge it--with with
special table with good one and it was
like it's not very special yes a bit
Florida International University FIU
they were like promoting this new type
of construction held like quickly they
built everything it's not good PR haste
makes waste buddy yeah so I'm gonna show
you guys a clip I've seen celebrating
how fast they were and then six people
died they're like oh yeah they were
celebrating when it first went up and
and a few days later it was just a few
days six days
oh damn they're like the submit they've
even hardened and [ __ ] yeah so and then
they were letting cars drive under it so
a lot of family members of the victims
are just obviously very upset like why
would you let cars go under that nose
even right that's uh and then there's
another thing I gotta add later but this
is is that CCTV didn't even like it
looks like there's people and people
that died in the car nowhere dude Wow
picture of a truck that was completely
[ __ ] crazy
well here's that enough for you Bart
that's horrible I'm kidding me so the
people instantaneously die no the
instantaneously died that would be the
best way out oh my god so holy [ __ ] yeah
it was crazy it's new cement technology
we did it to like the wires below like
the the reinforcements that they do it
fell on eight vehicles oh oh I've been
confirmed dead but they're all there are
also reports saying like that number
might go up damn because how many people
were involved in this [ __ ] a vehicles
yeah I think it was about nine nine
injured so yeah so they got smashed but
they're still alive so they just are in
community on the bridge to dad just
walked ahead like they had tables for
students to work on since this was this
bridge was meant to transport people
like students that live in this one
particular building into the school and
so previously about last year there was
a fatality when someone
crossing the street and they got hit by
car they got hit and so that's why they
decided to build this and then this
happens
and then that's stupid one person died
so they build this bridge and they kill
more people instead of just solve the
problem that's some [ __ ] when you
look at it that way it is and then the
[ __ ] that really really really sucks is
the fact that the lead bridge engineer
had warned that there was a crack in the
structure in a voicemail that was left
with the State Department of
Transportation two days before the do
that no one listened to him but the
employee was away out like they were out
on assignment and they didn't receive
the voicemail until after the bridge
fell that's their story but they were
also saying that in that voicemail the
engineer said that there was no concern
from a safety perspective for that
correct oh they didn't know so he's like
there's a crack in the structure but I
don't think it's a concern yeah I'm just
calling you to leave you this voice
message because I'm really [ __ ] bored
and have nothing else it's a
cover-your-ass
voice message it's a cover your own ass
something happens I said it put the
bridge up because I'm the lead engineer
on it yeah and like how does something
like this get made with all the checks
and balances and then like there's no
testing especially if it's something
else you can't put that up in six hours
six whole fair rides same same but I
still get on them I don't know why I
don't know Mike I don't trust you tape
let's go I was like that as a teenager
but I feel like the older I get the more
aware I am about my own mortality and
I'm like I can't know there's two that's
so true I was going down the mountain
the other day and I was like [ __ ]
shaking like this I'm like why I used to
be like spider-man
and then I hit it the second day and I
was going down like oh man I just had to
get used to it mm-hmm
I was so worried like oh my god that's
$100,000 if I broke my arm oh my god you
know like what you have our work for
like a week or whatever when you're kid
you're like I don't care if I get hurt
cuz they're not gonna cast that's cool
right and I'm all like there's $50,000 I
don't [ __ ] want to spend that [ __ ]
you're shaking cuz it's like you see
your bank account [ __ ] go- what were
you on what we wanna know we were like
we went to eat at this Mexican
restaurant on a mountain and we saw
these like rock structures and we wanted
to climb it so we decided to go down and
it was pretty dope because a lot of rock
climbers already had their things hooked
up ah so we just kind of spidered our
way down and we found a tree with a
hammock in it Oh picture that yeah and
we just climbed in there that's cool
yeah it was pretty fun but it was kind
of scary that is scary yeah do we were
in Bali and there was like these
slippery ice rocks cuz they're like oh
we're like proper hiking shoes okay so
we did but that it did you couldn't
prepare for this it was like slippery
ass rocks underwater and like you're
just there's so many rocks that you have
to step over I'm just like one little
slip of my ankle I think you're [ __ ]
the whole trip yeah it was so scary like
as a kid you'd be like clatters but as
an adult you're like I don't we're in a
foreign country like I don't have
insurance here you're like going through
the checklist to responsible add fun
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]